Can you have a good marriage without a good romantic life?
Bob's opinion:...
Can you have a relationship without the relations?
The decline of romantic life is the beginning of a breakup.
Sometimes, your relationship can be put back on track before it derails completely,...
...but in many cases a bad romantic life becomes a quick slide into completely separate lives...
...without each other.
No relationship, no matter how great it might be, can survive without sex.
Jane's opinion:...
It is not necessary to be romantic to have a good marriage.
It's more important to be good friends who like being with each other.
Being forced to be romantic just because others expect, it is not something people should have to do.
Love can be shown discreetly by the way a couple cooks dinner,...
...raises children, and does their professional job well.
This western notion of hearts and flowers and chocolate is for the birds.